hi welcome to the perform 2018 final
year project this project is mainly
looking to identify the genetic drivers
of cancer dependency in pancreatic
cancer this is the first video of a
series of videos which I will
demonstrate to you how you can actually
extract the data from the huge genomic
project called the drive project which
was published recently in cells so we
will use this data set to identify the
genes that are required for the
catalytic cancer cells survival as well
as proliferation
before we go into the technicality of
how to use the project drive data set
for our study I think it is important
for us to understand the background of
the project the term drive in the
project drive is actually a short form
for deep RNA AI interrogation of
viability effects in cancer the project
was conducted by Novartis one of the
major pharmaceutical company that
produced a lot of the oncological drugs
and the study was actually published in
2017 the main objective of the study was
to identify genetic drivers that drive
cancer cell survival and proliferation
the way how they identified those genes
involve a method called RNA interference
screen or RNAi ice-cream basically what
they did was transduce a Pugh
genome-wide lentiviral shRNA into a
series of cancer cell lines incubate
them for a certain period of time and
then recover the sequence of the SH RNA
by next gene sequencing by doing so the
shrna counts for genes that are required
for the cancer cell survival would be
expected to be lower compared to the
beginning of the study and these genes
would then be a good target for
development of specific inhibitors to
target for a specific type of tumors
what is interesting about the drive
project instead it is by far the most
comprehensive RNA I library screen
reported so far
targeting approximately 8,000 genes in
the human genome in about 400 different
cancer cell lines by analyzing the data
he was able to define the common as well
as specific cancer dependency genes in
different types of cancers this data
together with other large-scale genomic
data such published reasoning will allow
us to understand more clearly the
biological pathway that drive cancer
cell survival and hence lead to the
discovery of better drug target for
therapeutic purpose
the current study has three specific
aims first we wish to identify genetic
drivers that are required for pancreatic
cancer cell survival and second we would
like to identify the signaling pathway
that are associated with pancreatic
cancer cell survival and finally to
evaluate the biological effects of
targeting some of those pathways using
small chemical inhibitors
to achieve these objectives we will
first identify the new molecular targets
from the drive data set that are
required for pancreatic cancer cell
survival we will download the raw data
from the project drive database which
consists of more than 70 million data
points and is publicly available and
passed them through our studio and
delimit software the genes that are
significant a depleted will be identify
using the redundant si RNA activity
algorithm or in short the RSA algorithm
next the signature genes mediating the
pancreatic cancer cell survival will be
further annotated for gene ontology
pathways using reactant Davies and
string in this analysis candidate
targets with annotation resolved with
bonferroni corrector p-values of less
than 0.05 will be selected for future
study at the same time the gene
signature identified from the drive data
set will also be query against the
connectivity map database through
pattern matching analysis the database
consists of more than 1 billion data
points with genetic profiling
of more than 20,000 small molecule
compounds and 22,000 jeenetta construct
row knockdown genes or expression genes
in multiple cell lines a connectivity
score ranging from minus 100 - 100
provides a measure of the negative or
positivity connectivity of a drug to the
phenotype of interest positive values
indicates that the perturbation gave a
similar signature to the query and
negative values indicates that the
perturbation
gave a signature opposite to that of the
query the mean connectivity score of a
perturbation across the 4 cell lines
with a magnitude of less than minus 90
will be considered as hills finally
candidate drafter are being identified
from the connectivity map analysis will
be further tested in in vitro cell
culture model using SW 1990
exp c3 and asp c1 pancreatic cancer cell
lines and MTTs a overall the study is
expected to identify new molecular
targets for future development of
targeted therapy for pancreatic cancer
you